another friend of mine unfortunately
looks like he's going to be kept out of
the debate that would be Larry Elder
Larry Elder conservative libertarian
radio host in California ran for
governor of California he's running for
president now
he got gets to the airport at LAX he
thinks that he's qualified for the
debate he gets a call from Ronald
McDaniel at the head of the RNC saying
that he didn't qualify here's why
as you can see I'm at LAX in route to
Milwaukee and was just informed by the
RNC that I'm not qualified for the
debate why even though I exceeded the 40
000 individual donations required even
though I signed the pledge to support
the eventual nominee even though I
submitted three polls where I was at
least in one percent I was informed that
one of the polls is not eligible it's
the Rasmussen poll even though it was
the most accurate call in predicting
that Donald Trump would win in 2016.
they say it is affiliated with Donald
Trump and therefore it is not eligible
and I said to Ronald McDaniel the
chairwoman of the RNC is not affiliated
with me she said any poll affiliated
with any candidate is not eligible and
no one told me that until just now so
we're filing an emergency injunction to
get me up there this is absolutely BS
one of the candidates by the way offered
a twenty dollar gift certificate for a
one dollar donation that apparently is
okay okay so what he's referring to
there at the end I think it was bergam
who had no name recognition no support
so he decided to just give away gift
certificates if you gave a small
donation to his campaign he'd give you a
gift card of greater value to somewhere
else because he just wanted 40 000
donors to be able to get onto the debate
stage so what what about Larry here
the rules are the rules I guess he
technically doesn't qualify they can
keep him off the stage if they want
nobody's asked my opinion but if it were
me if I were running the RNC
I'd let him on
maybe he doesn't match the letter of the
law here but I think the spirit of the
law he's he's there because it's not as
though he's using the Donald Trump
polling firm he's certainly not using
the Larry Elder polling firm
I didn't realize that Rasmussen had this
direct relationship with Donald Trump
but even so rasmussen's a very respected
poll that's been around for a very long
time so it doesn't seem like this is
some cynical work around some
opportunistic rap I think he's got he
qualifies according to three polls one
of which I guess has a relationship with
Trump but don't forget Trump is
effectively running as the incumbent so
this is again a reason why this election
this primary race is different from any
other primary race in our lifetimes
because you've got the first president
running for a non-consecutive second
term since 1888. and so yeah I guess one
of the big polling firms has a
relationship with Trump
in a normal ordinary primary year that
would not be the case now it is I say
let him on the stage who cares who's It
Really Gonna Hurt
it's going to really hurt DeSantis
DeSantis is already going to be duking
it out with Vivek and Christy all night
long I don't think putting Larry Elder
up there is going to do very much
Larry Elders got an interesting
perspective he's got a slightly
different perspective than the other
candidates on that stage and frankly
Larry Elder is extremely libertarian so
it's not even like I particularly agree
with the ways in which his perspective
differ from the other guys on the stage
but I think come on you're gonna have a
debate have a debate
Trump is out he's not going to be
participating in some ways it's going to
make the debate more interesting in that
you're not going to have the big
King of the Hill Top of the Heap
chairman of the board sucking all the
air out of the room so you're gonna have
all these other guys sniping at each
other which will make it more
interesting if not uh more significant
for the race right now because Trump is
up 30 40 points so put him on the stage
come on why not let Larry up there right
now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles if
you're hiring you know that it's
incredibly difficult to attract top
talent with the current labor market
conditions it's even harder than ever
that is why you want to partner like sip
recruiter who gets it sip recruiter
knows how tough it is right now but
they've figured out solutions for the
problems that you're facing try them for
free at ziprecruiter.com
to reach more of the right people
ZipRecruiter posts your job to over 100
job sites zip recruiters smart
technology finds great matches for your
job and then lets you invite the most
qualified people to apply for your job
their pricing is really straightforward
you can stick to your budget with no
surprises team up with a hiring partner
like ZipRecruiter who understands what
you need four out of five employers who
post on recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the absolute number one
smartest way
to hire the reason they don't want him
on the stage is because I suspect the
other candidates don't want to have to
deal with Larry Elder because Larry
Elder is really really good in debates
he's really good in confrontational
scenarios Larry was just on The
Breakfast Club and he was
he was effectively called an Uncle Tom
Larry Elder's been called an Uncle Tom
his whole life I think he didn't he do a
movie called Uncle Tom and so he's dealt
with this smear his whole life and he
was somewhat subtly called an Uncle Tom
by the host of The Breakfast Club and
Larry just let him have it have you ever
heard a wake-up call no it is an
incident where a person of color forgets
that they are of color and are reminded
rather brutally by an unexpected Act of
racism
well I'm acutely aware Charlemagne that
I'm a black person just as you are a
black person and when Joe Biden insulted
you by saying you ain't really black we
don't know whether or not you want to
vote for me or vote for Donald Trump uh
the team see me that should have been a
wake-up call on your part how dare this
guy come in here and insult you a black
man and tell you you got to think a
certain kind of way I'm amazed that you
weren't mad about that
um it upset me just like I'm not letting
you upset me you know I mean I don't
tend to get upset over things like well
what I did say well you just not talk
about a wake-up call and it seemed to me
that that should have been a wake-up
call on your part to have a white guy
coming here who also said by the way uh
uh about Mitt Romney
um uh because he didn't want to put more
regulations on Wall Street going to put
y'all back in Chains and Joe Biden has
lied for decades about the Civil Rights
record claiming that he desegregated
movie theaters and restaurants in
Wilmington Delaware when he didn't any
didn't do any of that he lied and said
that he tried to visit Nelson Mandela
during apartheid South Africa he did not
and he came in here and told you you
aren't even black unless you think a
certain kind of way it seems to me that
should have been a wake-up call for you
but it wasn't apparently
absolutely devastating so that's part of
the reason I want him on the debate
stage I'm really looking forward to the
debate tonight I know some people are
saying it's not fair that Trump's not
there Trump needs to show up they need
to rip Trump apart if Trump showed up it
would be the Donald Trump show which I
get a kick out of I find it entertaining
but
the rest of the guys on stage would have
just been trying to take pot shots at
trump it probably wouldn't have worked
very well he would have maintained his
lead we wouldn't have really gotten very
much out of it now at least we're going
to get to see the differences between
all of the second tier and third tier
and fourth tier candidates and see if
any movement happens and see if right
now Ron DeSantis is still number two
maybe he can improve his position maybe
some candidates drop out and people
coalesce around DeSantis or maybe one of
the other candidates comes up takes that
number two spot from him it's going to
be a much less predictable interesting
debate than that and it'll be even more
interesting if Larry Elder gets up there
now to the point Larry Elder's making
here is a really good exchange and and
Larry is good at pointing out the
hypocrisy of the racism industry but
I don't think this is going to work in
the general if if Larry somehow became
the nominee or were a running mate or
something like that I don't think this
line would work in the general because
the black vote is overwhelmingly solidly
Democrat and we might say that's wrong
and that's stupid and they should vote
for republicans and I think all of that
but it's just a fact
the black vote has not budged in decades
and on top of that racism doesn't mean
anything anymore the word racist
according to the Democrats just means
bad
the work you'll just be accused of
racism if you in any way contradict
their views on anything or if you are
white at all you'll be called racist and
uh to the to the right because the right
has recognized that the word doesn't
mean anything I I think the the attack
has less
uh Venom than it used to
there's less potency than it used to so
you know Larry can come out and say well
Democrats are the real racists I just
don't think it's going to budge
anybody's vote
the Democrats who could be scandalized
by that and wake up and go to the other
side that's I think already happened
and the Republicans are much less afraid
of being called racist now because we
know how disingenuous it is so hope he
makes it to the debate I think he would
do a great job out there boy what a
great clip that was huh now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time